dos días después de la destrucción de la
presa de cajobska la región de gersón
sufre los impactos de las inundaciones
el presidente de Ucrania
visitó las zonas afectadas
llegó a un punto de evacuación de
civiles y habló con funcionarios a los
que agradeció sus esfuerzos Gracias a
todos los que ayudan a nuestro pueblo
Gracias a todos los que en el mundo
condenan los crímenes de los ocupantes
en rusos Rusia debe rendir cuentas por
todo lo que hace contra la vida y las
personas el kremlin asegura que Vladimir
Putin monitorea la situación pero no
tiene planes de trasladarse a gersón él
está supervisando la situación en la
región de gersón tras el acto de
Sabotaje después del Sabotaje de la
presa y la voladura de la presa ayer
como saben dio instrucciones al
Ministerio de emergencias para que
intensifique su trabajo allí y ayude a
la gente y para que se implique más
activamente en ayudar a mitigar los
efectos de las secuelas esto es un
desastre
según las autoridades ucranianas 17.000
personas ya han sido evacuadas y en las
zonas de la región controladas por Rusia
también se están llevando a cabo
operaciones de rescate según estas
imágenes difundidas por las autoridades
rusas
el ministro de agricultura de Ucrania
advierte de la pérdida de millones de
toneladas de cultivos como consecuencia
de las inundaciones